- For many of us working from home
has become a reality over the last months.
But clearly home office is not
without its own challenges.
Direct interaction with
your colleagues and clients
is now much harder than before.
Also you need to motivate yourself
and find your new rhythm
while working at home the whole day.
On top of that, I recently
conducted a survey
on my LinkedIn page,
asking you whether working
from home has improved
or not improved your
subjective work-life balance.
And here I must say, it
was quite interesting
for me to see that almost half of you
said that working from
home actually worsened
your subjective work-life balance.
So welcome to another Coffee Break
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on my channel
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And in today's video,
we are indeed going talk
about working from home,
about home office, and I want
to share with you three tips.
What you can do to improve
your working from home,
home office experience.
But before we jump into it,
let me introduce you to the
sponsor of this week's video,
Vidyard.
Vidyard is a free to use online tool,
which is designed for young professionals,
among others to review goals
and align projects with their
colleagues and just
making working from home
easier for them.
But now let's start with the three tips
and let's get into it.
The first tip is on how you communicate
while working from home.
And let me start by
reflecting on the differences,
from being co-located in an office
with your colleagues or clients,
or there's working from
home and not having
this direct interaction with
your clients or colleagues.
Because indeed what you
can do if you're on a call
located in one office,
is just walk by the desk
of one of your colleagues,
have an informal conversation,
invite them to a coffee
and just talk to them.
And any of those members of
the Firm Learning community
who have watched this channel
since the very beginning
might have also seen this video on the
golden consulting rule,
which is walk, talk, write.
So in the old times you
were told that usually
you should always try to walk by a client,
to directly talk to the person.
If that's not possible,
you try to talk to them
on the phone, for instance,
just calling them.
And only if this is not possible this way,
only then you write to them.
And I hope the reasons are quite obvious.
If you want to refresh on that,
I will link this video
somewhere above here for you
to check it out.
But clearly now in the
times of working from home,
the walk option is now
not possible anymore.
And also talking is more
difficult because you cannot have
these more informal conversations.
You will need to always
schedule a meeting,
book an appointment, to
then jump on a video chat
with one of these people, if
this is what you want to do.
So to overcome this, at
least to some extent,
one thing that really made
a difference in the company
where I currently work for
as chief revenue officer,
are tricks that help you to in a quick
and very straightforward way,
create videos about you
talking, create videos
where you can show certain
things, how you do things,
add explanations,
and then share these videos
with your colleagues.
But now think about that,
like typically the hurdles
to do this are quite big.
While your laptop might have a webcam,
you will usually need
specialized recording software
to create videos.
Then you will need editing
software to combine the videos
with maybe some other picture
feeds or screen recording
feeds for which you might need
additional software as well,
just to then create the video.
And then you will
usually need some type of
hosting solution where
then you can distribute
the video too, and then
share it from there.
This of course makes it
quite complicated and really
increases the hurdles of
creating videos for you to really
share with your team and
just simplify communication.
Therefore, I'm very happy
that the creators of Vidyard
decided to sponsor this
video on this topic,
and they have also contributed
to this channel because they
created a tool that helps
you to do exactly that.
They have a Chrome extension,
which is free to use,
which you can use to very
easily create videos of yours,
potentially also picture-in-picture videos
where both your screen and
your picture feed is recorded,
where you can then really
show certain things.
Let's imagine you have a big XM model
where you want to point
out a very specific problem
you are facing.
What I also very much laugh about this
is that this way of
working often helps you
to avoid unnecessary meetings
because now instead of you
just scheduling a meeting
and then blocking this time
in both or all the calendars
that are involved, now you
can just create a video
and then everybody can
watch it at their own
schedule, whenever they
have the time to do so.
But now, instead of me talking about it,
let me just show you how Vidyard works
with this little demo.
So this is the Vidyard
website on vidyard.com.
And the first thing that I
would recommend you to get
started with is to download
their free Chrome extension.
So if you click on here,
here you can see that you
will download it, and that
is completely free, indeed.
And I already did that,
which is why I added it
here to my extension bar.
And if you then click on that,
you can see that there are three options
that you can choose.
And all of this is part
of the free version.
You can record your screen and cam,
just your screen or just your cam.
So currently here I have the
screen and cam option included.
You see that here now the
input from my laptop webcam
is inserted and if I now
click Start Recording,
then indeed here I can choose
whether I want to record
the entire screen, window
or what exactly I want to do
and let's just go for the entire screen,
and then I can start recording indeed.
And now it gives me this timer, I guess.
So now I am recording, and for instance
now I could demonstrate to
you the different features of
Vidyard, so this could be now anything,
a spreadsheet that you are
showing to your colleagues,
or you could maybe also show something
to clients of yours,
maybe you are a marketer
and are having a sales
conversation with clients,
you wanted to demonstrate
what you can do for them,
just to show off your product.
This surely will be quite helpful.
And now if I'm done doing exactly this,
I just click here again on the extension,
and now you can see that the video here
is already appearing.
Now I have different options,
so I can for instance
customize it with a thumbnail so like
a little preview picture, you
get a link that you can share.
But now you could go on sharing it,
you're getting the link,
so let's just copy it,
can here change different
things that you can do with
password protection and so on.
But let's just leave it
here, in the free version
there's the very simple copy
link to share it, browser tab,
then this is what I can do indeed.
And now here I have shared my video,
I can start it.
And colleagues, clients,
friends can get access
to exactly this.
And now back here to the library,
so while there is a pro version of Vidyard
with even more also pretty great features,
the free version that I'm
currently also working with here
is already quite powerful,
and it offers you
unlimited uploads, unlimited hosting.
So really everything you need
to use a tool like Vidyard
to really simplify your
communication with your team,
hopefully avoid unnecessary meetings.
So Vidyard really is a great
tool to just walk through your
project ideas more quickly,
ask and iterate with your
teammates for feedback,
and really also avoid
misunderstandings based on that.
So I hope you were able to see the value
of using a tool like Vidyard
for the communication
with your team, because I clearly do.
And once again, they have
a free Chrome extension
that you can use to do the very same thing
that I just showed you.
So if you want to try it out yourself,
there is a link to this
free Chrome extension
in the video description below.
Tip number two that I would
like to share with you
is learning from meeting cadences
that were frequently used in consulting
and how these could apply
to you, to your team,
to really help you to
work together more closely
with your team in the
times of home office,
where you cannot just walk
by your team's office,
just talking to your colleagues
if you have a simple question.
And specifically the format
that I'm talking about is
daily team check-ins and
daily team check-outs.
So this is a format that was
very frequently applied in
consulting, so as the project lead,
you would set up every single morning,
usually around 8:30 am
or something like that.
The team check-in where
everyone from your project team
comes together, shares his or
her priorities for the day,
discusses what all the
individual consultants
are working on and
potentially also get input
from other teammates
that might be relevant
to the tasks of other
colleagues in the team.
From my experience, this
proved highly effective
to align everyone on the
mission and make sure
that all the important
tasks are worked on.
And in a similar way, the daily
check-outs are being used.
Rather usually around 5 or 6:00 pm,
you would come together with your team,
everybody would give an
update what they have been
working on, and potentially
also what they intend
to still work on later in the evening.
And of course, then this
also as a project lead
might be used as an opportunity
for you to potentially
help some of your teammates
to reprioritize their tasks,
if you feel like a person
would have still lots of work
to do that evening,
maybe you can just talk
and understand what the
things are that really
need to be done this evening,
what maybe the things are
that also have time to be
completed tomorrow or the next day
or later that week to
make sure that everybody's
not having too much of a
hard time during the day.
And especially in my last
role after consulting,
where I worked as a CTO
in a SME German retailer,
once we were hurt by
the new health situation
that started last year,
this is really what we
started to do every single day
in the leadership team,
this daily check-in, just
to get us all updated.
This really worked very, very well for us.
And I would just encourage
you to check this out,
try this out for your team as well,
if this is not yet something
that you already do.
The third tip that I have for
you is to reflect on your team
norms and team values
while now moving into this
new direction of home office
and working from home.
It seems to be very
obvious, at least to me,
that if you want to be
successful as a team
in this new environment,
you cannot just continue with
the team norms and team values
that you had, and that
maybe also worked very well
for you prior to this new situation.
What worked quite well for me
in the past is to get together
with your team and do a session
where you all reflect on
what the new norms, what the new rules are
that you will need as a team to succeed.
Let me share one very
specific example from my prior
conversations, and this was the
value of over-communication.
So in my last role,
we came together and came to
the conclusion that a crucial
new norm that we wanted to
establish was over-communication.
And this was created out
of the observation that
after a couple of months,
we realized that the number
of misunderstandings,
the number of miscommunications
seemed to have increased
due to the new situation.
Clearly, if you struggle
to really talk to people
face-to-face, it might
be more difficult to you
to also reach out, look for these more
informal communications,
maybe just check-ins
at the coffee bar, but you can just have
a brief conversation with
your colleague asking
if all the things you
discussed in the last meeting
were well understood.
These things are of course, missing now.
And it is even more important therefore,
to compensate this and
to communicate even more
namely to over-communicate
as we have then called it.
And specifically what this
meant is that the responsibility
on a task being understood,
on an important point being
shared and reflected
by everyone on the team
is now even more on the
sender, on the communicator
than before.
And here I also made the
experience that a tool like Vidyard
can really be tremendously helpful
to avoid miscommunication,
because instead of just writing
a message or maybe saying
something in a meeting,
you can share your thoughts in a video,
actually sharing what you
mean and showing what you mean
with very little effort.
So for instance, one
thing that you could do is
after a meeting, you can record
your main points in a video,
potentially also show exactly
the things that you mean,
maybe in a document,
in a file on some webpage on the internet,
and then share this
video with the teammates
that you're working on, just to make sure
that you are over-communicating indeed
and avoid any
misunderstandings on the team.
I trust that this can go a
very long way and really bring
you together and making sure
that you can work also remotely
in a highly effective way.
Now I would love to hear from
you, what are your favorite
home office or working from home tips?
I would love for you to write
that in one of the comments
that also have other fellow watchers,
here in the Firm Learning community.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date
on all my content.
I now once again want to thank Vidyard
for sponsoring this video and thereby
contributing to the
Firm Learning community.
And if you would like to use
the free Chrome extension
from Vidyard, check out the link to it
in the video description.
If you want to see even more from me,
I'm also active on other
channels, such as TikTok,
Instagram, or Twitch.
Feel free to check out the social links
in the video description as well.
And there you will also
find a sign-up link
to my regular email newsletter
where I also regularly
share updates about
consulting and career topics.
Thanks to all of you for watching,
my name is Heinrich from Firm Learning,
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So see you again next week, bye-bye.